>> Good afternoon. Happy
that I am here with you.
I am coming from Don Bosco,
you must be knowing about
Don Bosco schools colleges.
We also work for children on
the street, abandoned,
missing children.
There is another unit called
Don Bosco Young at Risk Forum.
So, I come from Don Bosco Young
at Risk Forum from Delhi.
Don Bosco YaR Forum,
it has 174 centers across
India working for various types
of children in
collaboration with NGOs,
governments, individuals,
more than 110 years in India.
We are working in about 20 states
or the union territories,
caring for about two lakhs
plus children who
are in need of care and
protection and in
conflict with the law.
Our services are
being on the street,
meeting the children
were abandoned, missing,
and giving them shelter,
education, health,
counseling, vocational training,
job placement, home placement.
Finally, settling them
back in the society.
We also do advocacy with
the government, creating systems,
especially for caring
of these kind of
children or young
people who are at risk,
including various types
of categories.
Young at Risk in short,
safety and growth and
development and are in need
of care and protection.
That is what we define
as Young at Risk.
There are various categories,
including HIV infected,
third-gender, of late
we have been thinking
about them trying to
start some work for them,
and school dropouts,
drug addicts,
those who are sexually
abused, physically
abused, emotionally,
and migrants is
another category we have been
looking at in the past
two, three years,
and any other category of
young children at risk
or young people at risk,
we do include as and when they
see and in the region
where we work.
Mission is inspired by
our founder Don Bosco.
A world where every child,
every young person
lives and grows towards
fullness of life,
that's our mission.
Okay, what do we do,
different projects that we
do that might interest you
because when I come here I
talk to you as technical person.
When I go down the line
to the NGOs I'm a techie,
when I go down the line
I had to talk completely
a different language otherwise
just they throw me out.
They say you are talking
something above our head.
The money that you are
asking us to invest on
technology if we could
save 100 more children,
that's the kind of
thinking NGOs had, not anymore.
They are also looking for,
because every work
is a model that
we create and it cannot be,
all the problem in
India we cannot
solve and we are coming
to a realization,
especially people who are working
in NGOs down the line are
realizing that we
need partnerships and
networks in order to
solve bigger problems,
all that we do is only a drop
in the ocean under model.
That's a great realization
that's coming up these days.
So, we are working in to
develop a biometric app.
It's already developed
called child BPA.
By which even other is
saying that it is not
able to track
children's biometric.
It has got its own problems.
So, we are trying to
work with Fujitsu,
trying to get the PAM biometric
and then we are experimenting in
Bangalore as well as in Delhi.
If everything goes well,
we will integrate it
with our system which
is already existing
called Child MISS,
management information
systems and services.
Migrant is something we
started three years ago,
Looking at different points
where we could work
with migrants.
App is in plan but nothing
has really taken off,
still the groundwork is going on.
JJ Alliance is
another important work
we do in the national level,
trying to improve the system of
juvenile justice in
partnership with
the government and also
educating down the line
implementing the law as well
as taking forward the system,
improvement of the system
with the government,
like trying to be a linkage,
that's another program we have.
Child Friendly Cities, I
overheard some of you talking
about what is that,
the smart cities.
In Child Friendly Cities,
we are developing
a model of child
friendly cities in 10 cities.
This year we have
started with four cities
in which we bring
in one platform,
NGOs, government
officials of the city,
the people of the place,
children as well as on
the platform trying to
understand the problem of
the children in the city so that
they're able to take care of
the children in the city,
making it much more
child-friendly,
and we are telling
the smart city builders,
if you don't include the element
of child-friendliness
in the city,
your city is not smart.
IUA is also in
collaboration with us.
We're trying to create
a child-friendly environment
in the city so that
children feel comfortable and
safe, that's another program.
Homelink Network is what I'm
going to be talking about.
Standards of care is
another aspect of caring of
children in the centers
where the children exists,
where the children stay with
us so that we are able to give
them wonderful care for
them, building up standards.
These are all in short,
some of the work that
we do across India.
Looking for collaboration
with the AI community.
What are the three problems
that I want to present to you?
The one is Run Away Children,
another one is the Lost Children,
another one is the Child Care.
What is the problem?
Every day, the statistic says,
there are about 174 children
go missing in India.
This is a world statistics.
You know that the number
keeps increasing.
Of late, you must have
heard about Bihar,
the nightmares the children
went through in some of
the NGOs, they have been raped,
even in the name
of- you went to say
that you're running
an NGO for children is
frightening these days because of
even the traffickers get into
the shoes of these NGO
and spoil the name.
So, traffickers can come in
different ways and that is
the danger for all these run away
children as well as
for the lost children.
The statistics again
says 1,011,569
they were lost and about
55,625 remain unidentified.
This is the government data,
we are not very sure
about that data.
It is much more. So, this
is the problem that I'm going
to be talking to you today.
What is this lost child?
Let's take the stages in which
a lost child goes through.
When the lost child
comes into the street or
the railway station or
the child is actually going
with the parents somewhere,
and then the child
gets lost, it happens,
it loses track of the parent
or the child comes
with some of friends
who want to see
the city or within
the city they get lost.
And they are just loitering
around in the platforms of
the railway stations or
in the bus stand or
in the marketplaces.
Our staff are there,
we have booths even in
Bangalore bus station
as well as Bosco,
here in Bangalore it's called
Bosco under the title
Bosco, it is functioning.
They have booths there in
the railway station platforms
as well as and our staff
are there 24 hours
trying to monitor if
any of these children.
They also educate
the caring community.
The platform sweepers and
other people are also educated to
identify these kinds of children
and bring the children
to these booths.
To the extent I heard
a story from a lady who
was involved in the flesh trade,
doing prostitution.
She identifies
sometimes girls whom
her superior would take and
then put her into prostitution,
she would rescue and tell
the child don't be here,
It's very dangerous, don't
live the life which I am living,
better go to that booth,
they will help you out.
So, that's how the society
is interested in.
Picking up these kinds of
children and bringing
them to safety.
Trafficker also, they
are also present on
the street trying to pick
up these kind of children.
So, when the child comes into
the NGO or the caretaker,
is identified by
the NGO or the public,
they're making effort in
searching for the child
and their parents.
When the child who is
lost comes to you,
most of the time
the child will tell you,
you know uncle, I am
from that temple.
You know there is a temple,
near that temple is my house.
Auntie, we are coming
from school and
that name of the school.
Hardly few words,
a few sentences,
which is what the child
will remember and then
the NGO worker has
to start tracking.
Who are these NGO workers?
They're just simple graduates
maximum or 10th
passer plus two pass.
This is what the NGO can afford.
So, these people that are able
to track these children and
then with these little
information that they give,
they go to the website,
they Google,
they search for the
police station,
they look for
the complain and they
try to send them back.
In the meantime,
the parents are going to
the nearby police station
and then they're going and
lodging a complain and
they are trying to
search for the child.
Maximum, the police will
receive the file in FIR,
mostly they don't do.
Our own the record says
about 60 to 70 percent
of the people
who lose their children
don't file an FIR,
first information
report with the police
because they are
afraid of the police,
if they're ordinary people.
If they are rich people, police
will go around the line,
search for the child.
Otherwise, nothing happens.
The FIR sleeps in the database
of the police and
the NGOs whatever the information
about the child which
they're collecting,
it is sleeping in
the database of the child.
Yes. They also know
which is the child who
is lost and they know
who is the child,
how they can know the child.
They have their own strategies,
as the NGOs have
their strategies.
The child is lost and
so it falls prey to
these kind of trap that they
set and so gets into the problem,
that's why the time the child
lands on the street
until it is rescued is
that very crucial time
you need to spend in order
to rescue the child.
Have I answered your question?
This strategy is- it
is- winning over the child
is their strategy.
By giving a sweet,
by promising work, by promising
to take them back home,
if the child is crying,
whatever the child is addressing
is the answer that they
will give accordingly.
Yeah. So, there is
a information about
the child is lying in
the database of the NGO,
the inflammation of the
complaint is lying in
the database of the
CWC or the police,
CWC does not have its own
database which is functional.
And the parents are searching,
and other NGOs might,
they might even go into
some other NGOs and give
some complaints and it is
the database also
is there lying all
separated not united in any way.
The challenges for
this lost child is how we
can reduce the time in
restoring the child.
The child tells you few words
with that how we can
search the police
station or the database,
how we can connect
that's a big challenge.
How can we help in tracing
the parents or guardian
with the words
uttered by the child?
It will just tell you school,
the child will tell you school,
or temple, or sweet shop,
or bus stand, friend's name,
father's name,
mother's name, these are
all minimum you could get.
How we can connect
various databases,
this is a big challenge
that we have.
How can we make
the distributed data
of child available
to police and CWC,
the child welfare committee
in each district who
can make a decision to
get the child back?
The analysis report
for the NGOs take
action which area
more children are coming and,
how we can solve
the problem etc. Yes.
>> [inaudible].
>> It depends that's why he
said there is a lost child,
there is a runaway child.
The lost child wants go home,
a runaway child does
not want to go home
because of smaller problems
of fight at home possibly.
So, the time factor
in taking the child back
home is a big challenge.
Last year in Chennai,
for example,
we had a child from
Chhattisgarh, nine years ago,
the child came to the NGO,
they made effort,
they took the child
once or twice to
Chhattisgarh ,they could not
identify the child's place.
Okay? So, they put him back here,
educated in Tamil medium,
the child reached
up to ninth class,
the child every year would
reveal some information.
With that they made effort
when he was in ninth class,
they traced the parent.
Yeah. After nine years
or eight years,
it's a joyful event,
but the child has
already studied in
Tamil medium and he cannot
go back to Chhattisgarh.
So, this is a challenge.
What is the mistake of the NGO?
They couldn't help it out
and the parent has tried,
but the databases,
the information is not
connected and so we are not
able to settle back home.
Such stories do come up
every year in every city.
The type of number of children
who come in, for example,
it's easy how much
a NGO can employ,
you'll get 40 children in
Bangladesh, for example,
40 to 60 new children
come every day into
the city and counseling
40 to 60 children,
what is a challenge and
an amount of time that is spent.
These are all challenges
that we need to.
Restoring a runaway child.
Runaway child will come and
change everything
of his identity.
The child comes to the street,
it is lucky that you're able to
identify and bring
the child home,
and then when you
start counseling,
if he is from a Muslim community,
he will say, "I am James."
He'll change his name,
he'll change his religion.
"What is your name?" "I am Ram."
But he must be Mohammed actually.
After 16 years, we found out that
one child was
a Muslim not a Hindu.
This is how they will change.
They'll change their identity,
they'll forget
their identity also.
So, this is a challenge there.
In this place of runaway child,
collecting a biometrics and
identifying possibly
is a solution.
That's where we are running
an experiment with
this biometric.
This disputed database,
Aadhar is having its data,
but how we can connect
it, very difficult.
Then Homelink has its own data,
TrackChild has it's own data,
Khoya Paya has its own data.
All these are having
independent data not connected,
but they are willing to join
hands in order to
solve the problem.
The challenge is this again,
which bio-metric will
work for the children?
Others says it will not work,
so what is the solution?
Can we not create
a common platform in
which all these biometrics
can be tested out?
This is what we had been
discussing for
the past two years with
Microsoft and some solution
or some model has emerged,
we have not yet implemented.
Can the AI platform provide
enough data for the counselor to
identify the child and
help the child to
get back home soon?
Because the pattern in
which the children talk,
sometimes it is the same.
So, can these AI give
the counselor who is an ordinary
person with their degree?
Should be assisted
in order to identify
what category and what are
the problems
this child is saying,
and what possibly in
the experiences that
we have with the data
whatever is the solution.
Can AI provide data to assess
the problem of the child
based on his behavior,
reaction, words used, and
accordingly to the counseling
and correction process?
Is a challenge. Under care
and protection
the third problem. Yes.
>> [inaudible].
>> One minute, I'll finish.
The care and protection is,
again, the child is
staying with us,
he maybe an orphan
and he has nobody,
we know that he has
nobody and so we
start taking care of the child.
But whatever may
be the situation,
in a particular place
like Bangalore,
they may be very
innovative in taking
care of the child on physical,
development, social,
emotional, intellectual,
spiritual, care et cetera.
All these level, each one
will be innovative.
But all these innovation
will lie within one NGO.
Suppose these all get
formulated into
an analysis and we are
able to identify
these innovation and put
it as a standard for
the whole of India,
or the whole of the world,
and then measure accordingly
whenever you ask
a few inputs that NGO
people are ready to get
and free data it inside,
and with that every quarter
we are able to assess and say,
this child is not
okay emotionally,
this child is not located
in the knowledge wise,
and then take measures.
So, when we are able
to give them feedback,
they will always act.
There is every chance
that there is
a corrective measures.
So, with the data available,
can we not provide this?
This is a challenge.
Can we check with
few input variables
whether the child is progressing
in all forms of growth?
Can we create standards?
What are the new challenges
that are emerging with that?
Because every year the type
of children who come
and the type of challenges
that they throw is new,
and the corrective measures
cannot be same.
So, we have with us
about three lacks
data in our database.
In the past six to 10 years
we have been working
with the visual basic starting
with the debasing visual.
Basically, I've been having
databases and now we have
in Microsoft Azure platform
also data about
three lakhs we have,
and we have home placed
about one lakh odd,
and institutionalized
about 67,000.
They're in contact about 13,000,
all these has only entered data
not all the NGOs enter their
data,this is entered data.
But the actual work is
enormous and the children who
died also these data also
we are able to maintain.
The missing complaints we have
received in our institutes across
India we have about 8,338 traced,
complaint received
is about 19,300.
So, with our own manual systems
of search et cetera,
we are able to
solve this problem.
This is the design that has
been proposed by
Microsoft that we
been working with in us
with one of the guy.
So, he was suggesting to us,
if you go with this design,
you'll be able to
connect the database,
we're still dreaming about it
hope it happens soon. Thank you.
>> Thank you [inaudible]
for the inspiring story.
Now in the interest
of time and making
sure that everybody
gets a fair chance,
we'll take one question.
So, I can see, yeah. One please.
>> Thank you very much.
I have a question.
What has been your experience
with the police
and have you been able
to access their data?
How useful has it been?
>> Our experience
with police has been
buried because some states
they're quite open,
some states they say we have
our own database because
each one is married
to their own data,
that is why we came up with
a shared model and each database
has its own specifics.
See for example BBA [inaudible] ,
they have specific data
on on child labor.
We don't need all that
for identifying children,
we need only few elements.
Police have lots of
other information
which is not required for
identifying the child,
so, we are only dialoguing
with them and saying,
you don't need to
share everything,
you don't need to share
common elements which will be
helpful for identification,
we think that with this process,
it will be possible.
Some police, some states
they have been very very
helpful in implementing
together, yes.
Bangalore for example,
we share data.
At least in Excel form
they keep sharing
among each other,
the two databases [inaudible] .
>> Thank you [inaudible].